for the second night running grenfell
tower burned
pockets of fire remained in difficult to
reach places
fire crews have searched almost all the
building
but the toll of this blaze is still far
from clear
residents of the tower block spent the
night in makeshift shelters
the ordeal they have been through is
difficult to imagine
and that ordeal continues as they wait
for news of loved ones
friends neighbors
so many are missing and so many must be
feared dead
amid the grief and horror the question
why
how could this building renovated only
last year be engulfed so quickly how
could safety measures apparently fail
the fire was quite small to start off
with there was a gentleman standing in
in and amongst the crowd
stating that that was his flat that was
on fire and that a refrigerator had
blown up like i said very small fire
within minutes from the left and from
the right and from the above it just
spread so rapidly it's the cladding
it's the cladding i spoke to a um a
resident that has been living there for
40 years and she said that there has
been fires there but they've always been
contained this is the first fire that
has spread around the building and
spread so fast and that cladding went up
less than a year ago well the problem is
there is no fire alarms running working
i don't know why i haven't heard no
alarm i only heard in my house smoke
alarm
an activist group says it had been
predicting a catastrophe for years
this is one image from the group's
website
we repeatedly reported concerns to the
tenant management organization of the
royal borough of kensington and chelsea
including fire safety concerns which
were not investigated
during the regeneration works
the authorities are promising a full
investigation
it's still far too early to really know
what happened
amid the trauma signs of solidarity
food
clothes toys donations have been pouring
in for those who lost their homes and
everything in them
the response is unbelievable i mean the
church was filled with donations almost
by 10 o'clock we love our community and
we're here we're heartbroken for our
community
this is
a
terrible
for this community but we are pulling
together the people that have nothing
to do
with the people that have nothing
a community hit by tragedy
the true extent of that tragedy will
only become clear in the days ahead
as rescuers comb the shell of grenfell
tower